immer wieder interessant um die
kanzlerin zu zitieren was man aus corona
alles lernen kann
letzten sommer haben wir zum beispiel
gelernt das virus mag deutsche
schlachthöfe was mit falsch belüfteten
kühlräumen zusammen hängt aber auch mit
ausbeutung
nachdem toni skandal sie erinnern sich
hat die bundesregierung daher gelobt
damit muss schluss sein für immer
andererseits kriege ich dann wenn die
das durchziehen noch mein holzfäller
stick für 199 herzlich willkommen zu zdf
spezial
alle reden immer nur über corona dabei
ist unsere grillsaison in gefahr
mit till reiners uns allen droht der
lehre grill das berühmte worst case
szenario also behauptet die deutschen
fleischindustrie die kommende
grillsaison steht auf der kippe
zumindest wenn die groko ernst macht und
wirklich ausbeutung verbietet zb durch
leiharbeit sollte per gesetz noch diesen
monat beschlossen werden
totaler wahnsinn leute es geht um die
wurst das wichtigste bei einer akuten
bratwurst ist das nur hinterherfahren
besteht um das was mit liebe gemacht hat
[Musik]
bratwurst besteht aus liebe knorpel und
ausbeutung
deswegen hat die fleischindustrie jetzt
doch noch mal ein gutes wort für sich
eingelegt bei der cdu und mit erfolg
auch die union findet plötzlich ganz
ohne leiharbeit geht es ja nun auch
nicht gerade in der krise so da müssen
auf die schnelle milliarden schweine
geschreddert werden
da wäre es doch schön wenn man sich kurz
und billig in rom an dazu holt der
koalitionspartner kritisiert den
unternehmen werde flexible
personalbeschaffung verboten etwa zur
grillsaison in summe ich finde dass die
fleischverarbeitende betriebe die
möglichkeit haben in dieser zeit
kurzfristig personal anzuheuern weil wir
werden das grillen nicht in den winter
verlegen
genau köln im winter das wäre pure
anarchie warum sollten jetzt überhaupt
leiharbeit und werkverträge verboten
werden weil letzten sommer der politik
plötzlich aufgefallen ist das zeigt ganz
schlimm ausgebeutet wird in den
schlachthöfen das vor den gar nicht so
klar
sicher die politik hat selbst die
möglichkeiten dazu geschaffen aber kann
ja keiner ahnen dass die möglichkeit so
schamlos genutzt wird sowie im
sympathischen schlachtbetrieb channels
sie erinnern sich vielleicht dass das
waren ja 12.500 mitarbeiter aus mehr als
80 nationen
kollegiales verhalten und gute
freundschaften vorprogramm ja hallo auch
noch mal von meiner seite ich dachte
jetzt nicht an die vielen freundschaften
sondern vor allem an die weit über 2000
corona infizierten durch den schlachthof
denn bei turniers gehen wir unseren weg
gemeinsam auch nach der arbeit
fitnessprogramme familienfeste und
fußball betriebssportmannschaften sind
nur ein teil ist genau der andere teil
des angebots waren hungerlöhne
ich will jetzt turniers nicht darauf
reduzieren die angestellten haben wir
auch von drohungen massenunterkünften
und unbezahlten überstunden berichtet
warum hilft die cdu dieser branche schon
wieder perfekt fraktionschef brinkhaus
kommt aus rheda-wiedenbrück home auf
tennis wer ist aber unabhängig also ist
jetzt nicht so als wird der mann ständig
über fleisch reden zum beispiel ich
kenne viele viele anständige leute die
essen gerne mal einen nackensteak
liedern heute auch mein nacken steak
essen ja diese nackensteak es ja dass
die leute den nacken steak essen auch
zunehmend andere sachen essen du bist
böse weil wir jetzt in akustik ist gut
ausbeutung hatte auch immer zwei seiten
wie ein nackensteak auf der einen seite
lohnsklaven auf der anderen seite lecker
fleisch also menschenwürde immer gerne
aber regeln braucht eine ausnahme
sie kennen das von der ampel immer
halten wenn rot ist es sei denn man hat
es eilig oder kinder schlagen darf man
nicht es sei denn es sind richtig nerven
kinder deswegen mein vorschlag wir
werden uns rigoros gegen beschissene
arbeitsbedingungen
es sei denn es ist ein monat mit r oder
man hat richtig hunger
denn wie sagt clemens tönnies völlig zu
recht
[Musik]
ja
eben unseren schweine zerlegt der nach
zwölf stunden arbeit in der kälte weiß
jetzt noch zwei unbezahlte stunden dann
gibt es auch nackensteak vom grill
wollen wir das wirklich nehmen guten
abend
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da